nos negamos a ser silenciados con ese
lema fue convocada una protesta armada
para el mediodía de este domingo lo que
mantiene en alerta a las autoridades de
eeuu sus organizadores la han calificado
como la manifestación armada más grande
que ocurrirá en suelo estadounidense en
la capital se prevé que vaya desde el
washington memorial hasta la casa blanca
y también hay movilizaciones convocadas
contra los capitolios de los 50 estados
michigan virginia wisconsin y
pensilvania están entre los estados que
activaron la presencia de la guardia
nacional para reforzar la seguridad la
atención en washington dc ha hecho que
gran parte del centro quede restringido
o bloqueado al menos hasta el 21 de
enero y la alcaldía ha pedido a los
cerca de 700.000 residentes que
permanezcan en sus casas durante la
jornada de posesión de joe biden este 20
de enero
creo que vamos a volver a una nueva
normalidad
y creo que todo nuestro país tiene que
hacer frente a como nuestro aparato de
inteligencia y nuestro aparato de
seguridad a todo nivel
tiene que enfrentar una muy presente y
muy real amenaza para nuestra nación
tenemos una responsabilidad especial en
que haya una transición pacífica de
poder en nuestro país
además para el día de la juramentación
más de 31.000 efectivos de la guardia
nacional y de las agencias de seguridad
estarán encargados de proteger la
capital
este sábado unidades policiales del
capitolio arrestaron a un hombre que
intentaba entrar en el perímetro
controlado con una acreditación no
autorizada un arma de fuego y más de 500
balas pese a los reportes del fbi y de
las agencias de inteligencia sobre
posibles ataques
el presidente de electo joe biden ha
asegurado sentirse seguro de cara a la
juramentación que lo convertirá en el
presidente número 46 de eeuu